Hi, this is Joel Blackstock with the Tablet Therapy Collective podcast, and today we're going to talk about corporate tech monopolies ruining therapy. So last weekend, BetterHelp, which is an online subscription therapy company, settled with the Federal Trade Commission for almost $8 million in fines, which will be returned to consumers for selling therapy patients data that is confidential. And they sold the data to Facebook and Snapchat. And this isn't justice, so please hold your applause there. And this company, whose name really is the word better of people who have had a negative experience with the company. last year where YouTube influencers that a lot of like Gen Z children and young adults watch were paid without disclosing it to vlog about conditions that they had. And the allegation was
大家好，我是来自Tablet Therapy Collective播客的Joel Blackstock。今天我们要谈谈企业科技垄断如何破坏心理治疗。上周末，在线订阅心理治疗公司BetterHelp与联邦贸易委员会（FTC）达成和解，支付了近800万美元的罚款。这笔钱将退还给消费者，因为该公司出售了患者的机密治疗数据，而且是卖给了Facebook和Snapchat。这根本算不上正义，所以请别急着鼓掌。这家公司的名字里确实带有“更好”（Better）这个词，但对于那些有过负面体验的人来说，情况并非如此。去年，许多Z世代青少年和年轻人关注的YouTube网红在未披露的情况下，受雇宣传他们所患的疾病，而指控称……
that the conditions, the mental health conditions that they were, the influencers were saying that they had were made up or exaggerated, and they claimed that BetterHelp had treated the conditions. And a lot of YouTube influencers talked about it. And, you know, children look up to that community, so it's kind of an abuse of power there. Maybe it's a little shady marketing, but it's not illegal. Whereas this new thing is not getting the attention that I think it needs to get because it's not just illegal. It's a huge deal.
这些网红声称自己患有的心理健康疾病是编造或夸大的，他们还声称BetterHelp治愈了这些疾病。许多YouTube网红都谈论过这件事。你知道，孩子们很崇拜那个群体，所以这算是一种权力滥用。也许这只是营销手段有点阴暗，但并不违法。然而，这件事之所以没有得到应有的关注，是因为它不仅违法，而且性质极其严重。
If I had done this as a therapist, if any one therapist did this, there would be giant consequences that when a company that makes millions of dollars did this to millions of patients, nothing happened. Nothing happened to them. So, you know, one of the allegations that has gone on for a really long time with BetterHelp is that they say that they're going to charge you for one session, but it's really hidden in the fine print that it's a subscription and that it's $320 a month. A lot of people have complained that there are repeated no-shows where the therapist doesn't show up, which happens. I mean, it may happen to you at Taproot, but it seems to be a big problem and that they charge you anyway, even
如果我作为一名治疗师做了这种事，或者任何一位治疗师做了这种事，都会面临巨大的后果。但当一家赚取数百万美元的公司对数百万患者这样做时，却什么事都没发生。他们没有受到任何惩罚。你知道，长期以来针对BetterHelp的指控之一是，他们声称只收取一次会话的费用，但实际上在细则中隐藏了订阅条款，费用高达每月320美元。许多人抱怨说，治疗师经常无故缺席，这种情况确实会发生。我的意思是，在Taproot可能也会发生，但这似乎是一个大问题，而且即便如此，他们还是会照常收费。
though the therapist cancels the session or that they give you paperwork that takes up the whole hour. So you never even really get to meet with the therapist. Those are some complaints that are around. I mean, you may encounter that at any big company, but this thing about selling data to Facebook is unprecedented for a couple reasons, and I just think people should know about it because it's a big deal. You know, this sale of data, you know, the FTC is saying that they have to give this money back to people that was ill-gotten. That's not a punishment. Okay. Like these companies have fines baked in to their business structure, or they make more money breaking the law than they have to pay back when they get caught. So it's not a punishment. It does. It's not a deterrent. You know, there's no, their risk tolerance, this is all factored into it. And unless you start to have real consequences for these companies, then we are going to turn this profession into something that people stay away from because they are afraid. And people need mental health care. People kill themselves. People get addicted to opiates. Fentanyl is rising. Like, we need to be making healthcare something that people trust.
即使治疗师取消了会话，或者他们给你一堆需要填写的文书工作，占用了整整一个小时，导致你根本没能见到治疗师。这些都是周围存在的一些投诉。我的意思是，你在任何大公司都可能遇到这种情况，但出售数据给Facebook这件事在几个层面上都是前所未有的。我认为人们应该了解它，因为它事关重大。你知道，FTC说他们必须把这些不义之财退还给人们，但这根本不是惩罚。这些公司的罚款早已计入商业成本，或者说他们违法赚的钱远多于被抓后需要支付的罚款。所以这根本不是惩罚，也不是威慑。他们的风险承受能力已经把这些都考虑进去了。除非这些公司开始面临真正的后果，否则我们将把这个行业变成一个人们因为恐惧而避之不及的地方。人们需要心理健康护理。人们会自杀，会沉迷于阿片类药物，芬太尼问题日益严重。我们需要让医疗保健成为人们信任的东西。
And these companies are making healthcare something that people are afraid of as a matter of, you know, just perception. I mean, the perception is real there. But, you know, people aren't just going to just trust this one company. They're going to read these things, and they're going to see what happens, and they're not going to go to therapy at all. And that's a pretty big consequence. So, you know, when you go to therapy, there's more than just this expectation that what you talk about will be private. You know, HIPAA laws, the healthcare protection laws mean that, you know, your therapist, if they knowingly disclose information
而这些公司正在让医疗保健变成人们恐惧的对象，至少在认知层面是这样。这种认知是真实存在的。人们不会只信任这一家公司，他们会阅读这些新闻，看到发生了什么，然后他们根本就不会去寻求心理治疗了。这是一个非常严重的后果。所以，当你去接受心理治疗时，不仅仅是期望你谈论的内容是私密的。你知道，HIPAA法案，即医疗保健保护法，意味着如果你的治疗师故意泄露关于你的信息……
about you, they're breaking the law or anything that you say. You know, there's a couple of exceptions to that. If you're suicidal or homicidal actively, or if you're making or accessing child pornography, you know, we're mandated reporters of that. But other than that, I mean, that relationship is sacrosanct. And, you know, if one therapist had done this, they would be civilly liable to be sued. They would lose their license, probably, if they did it intentionally or repeatedly, and they would be kicked out of an insurance panel. And this company had none of those things happen. They were just like, okay, you took some money, so what do you give a little bit of it back? If I rob a bank, and they tell me, yeah, just give the money back to the bank, but we're not going to do anything
他们就是在违法。你知道，这有几个例外情况。如果你有自杀或杀人倾向，或者你在制作或获取儿童色情制品，我们是强制报告员。但除此之外，那种关系是神圣不可侵犯的。如果有一位治疗师做了这种事，他们会在民事上承担责任并被起诉。如果他们是故意或反复这样做，他们可能会失去执照，并被保险小组除名。而这家公司却什么事都没有。他们只是被告知，好吧，你拿了一些钱，那就退还一点回去吧。如果我抢劫了一家银行，他们告诉我，是的，把钱还给银行就行了，但我们不会对你做任何……
else, what does that teach me? And, you know, and then the thing that is beyond the pale to me is that after they did this, they released a statement saying we didn't do anything wrong, which tells you what they are going to continue to do. Okay. You know, Better Help removed all of the links that I put on their news articles because they don't want to be associated with their own behavior. I tagged them in a couple articles. Just the articles that were saying their own press release. They were saying this happened. Well, they didn't want that on their social media because they don't want to be associated with their own behavior. And that's strange because they released a statement that said, this settlement, which is
其他处理，这能教给我什么呢？而且，最让我无法接受的是，在他们做了这些事之后，他们发表了一份声明说“我们没有做错任何事”，这说明了他们未来还会继续这样做。BetterHelp删除了我放在他们新闻文章上的所有链接，因为他们不想与自己的行为挂钩。我在几篇文章中标记了他们，仅仅是那些报道他们自己新闻稿的文章。文章说发生了这些事，但他们不想让这些出现在他们的社交媒体上，因为他们不想与自己的行为挂钩。这很奇怪，因为他们发表的声明说，这次和解……
no admission of wrongdoing, allows us to continue to focus on our mission. That's why we settled with the FTC. They didn't do anything wrong. And that's either a really weird way to misspell, I'm sorry, or they don't think they did anything wrong. And they're telling you that. And it's not just this one company. I mean, the reason that I wanted to put this out there is because people need to understand how grave of a risk this is to the profession. You know, like, I know therapists that work for BetterHelp that are good people, and they're good therapists. And it's not their fault. They're not in control of these things. Ethical employment is a luxury, okay?
并不代表承认任何不当行为，这让我们能够继续专注于我们的使命。这就是我们与FTC和解的原因。他们没有做错任何事。这要么是一种非常奇怪的道歉方式，要么就是他们真的认为自己没做错。他们就是这样告诉你的。而且不仅仅是这一家公司。我想把这件事说出来，是因为人们需要了解这对整个行业构成的风险有多严重。我知道有些为BetterHelp工作的治疗师是好人，也是优秀的治疗师。这不是他们的错，他们无法控制这些事情。道德就业是一种奢侈，明白吗？
Like, social workers and LPCs, like like don't make a ton of money. And if you have to pick between working from somebody that's for somebody who's kind of icky and paying your mortgage or feeding your kids, you're going to work for somebody who's kind of icky. I would do it, too. So it's not that people who work for better help are bad. That's not the point. That's that if these things are allowed to happen as precedent, then this industry is something that people will no longer
社会工作者和LPC（持证专业咨询师）赚的钱并不多。如果你必须在为一个有点恶心的人工作以支付房贷或养活孩子，和失业之间做选择，你最终会选择为那个有点恶心的人工作。我也会这么做。所以，并不是说在BetterHelp工作的人是坏人，重点不在这里。重点是，如果这些事情被允许作为先例发生，那么这个行业将不再是人们……
trust and no longer use. And they shouldn't, right? I mean, one of the things that BetterHelp said in their statement was that, you know, they didn't disclose anything that was identifiable or anything that wasn't encrypted to Facebook, all right? Well, one of the things that they released purportedly is email addresses. My email address is joelblackstock at gettherapybirmingham.com. That's pretty identifiable. If you see that, you know who I am and where I work. I mean, most people's email address is public because it's an email address and we want to get email. If nobody knows what it is, then they can't email you, you know? And so another thing that they did when they released all this stuff is you know they took
信任并使用的行业。他们也不应该信任，对吧？BetterHelp在声明中说，他们没有向Facebook披露任何可识别身份的信息或未加密的信息。好吧，他们据称泄露的信息中就包括电子邮件地址。我的电子邮件地址是joelblackstock@gettherapybirmingham.com。这非常容易识别。如果你看到这个，你就知道我是谁以及我在哪里工作。大多数人的电子邮件地址都是公开的，因为我们需要接收邮件。如果没人知道它是什么，他们就无法给你发邮件。所以，当他们发布所有这些东西时，他们还做了另一件事，就是……
the intake question that said have you ever been in therapy before which is you're going to get a history if you go to see a therapist the therapist wants to know if you're going to be in therapy before that's part of an intake question and they're like well that doesn't count because that was just part of the app that you could use for self-help but that you later use for therapy it was an intake question on there so it's not really part of the app that you could use for self-help, but that you later used for therapy. It was an intake question on there. So, it's not really part of your therapy with your therapist. You know, what the hell?
他们把那个问“你以前接受过心理治疗吗”的摄入问卷也包括进去了。如果你去看治疗师，他们肯定会了解你的病史，这是摄入问卷的一部分。他们却说，这不算数，因为那只是你可以用于自助的应用程序的一部分，后来才用于治疗。这明明是上面的一个摄入问卷，所以它并不是什么你可以用于自助的应用程序的一部分，而是后来用于治疗的。这明明是上面的一个摄入问卷。所以，这怎么能说不是你与治疗师治疗的一部分呢？这到底是怎么回事？
If I took pictures of the people in my waiting room, or I had a live stream of people walking into therapy. And I was like, well, you don't know what happened in the room, so you don't know that they're getting therapy. I mean, anyone can make the connection that somebody who is saying, who's going to a therapy app to get therapy is wanting to get therapy and also when you're you're asking them within a health care setting have you been in therapy before which is privileged information you didn't ask them you know on the street you ask them in the context of trying to pair them with a therapist and get a history so that that is health care information which this company is saying isn't which should really make you afraid of these apps it's not just better help you know a lot of these companies do the same thing consumer reports had a really good article where they and they did a study they actually did some reporting where they looked at what these companies, and they did six different companies, where they were sending
如果我给候诊室里的人拍照，或者直播人们走进治疗室的过程，然后我说，好吧，你不知道房间里发生了什么，所以你不知道他们是在接受治疗。任何人都能联想到，一个去心理治疗应用程序寻求治疗的人就是想要接受治疗。而且，当你在医疗环境中询问他们“你以前接受过心理治疗吗”时，这是受保护的信息。你不是在街上问他们，而是在试图为他们匹配治疗师并获取病史的背景下问的。所以这是医疗保健信息，而这家公司却说不是。这真的应该让你对这些应用程序感到恐惧。不仅仅是BetterHelp，很多公司都做同样的事情。《消费者报告》有一篇非常好的文章，他们做了一项研究，实际上进行了一些调查，查看了这些公司在做什么。他们调查了六家不同的公司，发现它们都在……
data to, and they're all sending data to Facebook, okay? So, and Facebook, in my mind, bears some responsibility. There are laws that should be in place. I mean, the law says, you know, that they're better help, the responsibility is on them to keep this stuff private, but you know what you're buying. Like they, they understood the data that they were buying. Like, so this is from the FTC's complaint. This is from the actual document. They said that there was a question called, have you ever been in counseling or therapy before? And the analyst revealed to Facebook that this event meant that the user completes the questionnaire marking that they have been in therapy before. The therapy
向Facebook发送数据。在我看来，Facebook也负有一定责任。应该有相应的法律。法律规定BetterHelp有责任保持这些信息的私密性，但你知道你在买什么。他们理解他们购买的数据。这是来自FTC的投诉，来自实际文件。他们说有一个问题叫“你以前接受过咨询或治疗吗？”，分析结果向Facebook揭示了该用户完成了问卷，标记了他们以前接受过治疗。治疗……
thereby disclosing millions of visitors and users prior therapy to Facebook. Okay. So it's better help's fault because they're the healthcare provider. But Facebook knows that they're buying a medical history, right? If you fence stolen goods, if you know you're buying stolen goods, then I think you have some ethical responsibility there, too. And no one's talking about that. And then after they did that, BetterHelp released a statement saying we didn't do anything wrong. There's even like a little part at the end where they're like, we understand that the FTC is trying to create a new precedent.
从而向Facebook披露了数百万访问者和用户的既往治疗史。好吧，这是BetterHelp的错，因为他们是医疗保健提供者。但Facebook知道他们买的是医疗记录，对吧？如果你销赃，如果你明知自己在买赃物，那么我认为你在道德上也负有责任。没人谈论这一点。在他们做了这些事之后，BetterHelp发表声明说我们没有做错任何事。最后甚至还有一小部分内容说，我们理解FTC试图开创一个新先例。
It's like this isn't anything to do with the Federal Trade Commission. You broke the law and you had to give back some of the money. This should be the Justice Department, in my opinion. So, I mean, I think that these corporate monopolies have the potential to ruin therapy because they're going to get so big that you have to use them. The parent company of BetterHelp is Teladoc. And if the brand gets toxic, I mean, even if CNN and Fox News deign to care about all this potentially or allegedly criminal stuff and report it, the brand could just get so toxic that they dissolve it and then they continue to do the same service under a different name or under Teladoc. And a lot of insurance companies are starting to require therapists to use Teladoc. I want to use Simple Practice because I know what they do with their data.
这跟联邦贸易委员会有什么关系？你违法了，你不得不退还一些钱。在我看来，这应该是司法部的事。我认为这些企业垄断有潜力毁掉心理治疗，因为它们会变得如此庞大，以至于你不得不使用它们。BetterHelp的母公司是Teladoc。如果这个品牌变得有毒，即使CNN和福克斯新闻屈尊关注所有这些潜在或涉嫌犯罪的事情并进行报道，该品牌也可能变得如此有毒，以至于他们解散它，然后以不同的名称或以Teladoc的名义继续提供同样的服务。许多保险公司开始要求治疗师使用Teladoc。我想使用Simple Practice，因为我知道他们如何处理数据。
And I know the history of that company. And when we put my company together, when we put our collective together, we looked at that because we cared about the people who came to see us. And if you don't give the providers a choice, then they have to use these services because people have insurance and they're required to use Teladoc. I don't know what Teladoc does with the data. I'm not accusing them of anything, even though BetterHelp is, they own it, you know, so they're kind of responsible for that.
我知道那家公司的历史。当我们组建我的公司，组建我们的集体时，我们研究了这一点，因为我们关心来看我们的人。如果你不给提供者选择权，那么他们就必须使用这些服务，因为人们有保险，而保险公司要求使用Teladoc。我不知道Teladoc如何处理数据。我没有指控他们任何事情，尽管BetterHelp是他们拥有的，所以他们对此负有某种责任。
But I don't want to say anything that's going to get me in legal trouble, but I don't want to use that company. And if the insurance company tells me that I have to do it, I have the choice of not taking insurance or using their software. And I think that those monopolies are bad. And I want the consumer to know about it, and I want the providers to know about it. And companies like this make more money breaking the law than they have to pay back when they get caught. That is a bad precedent. You know, if you send executives who do this to jail, they will stop because they don't want to go to jail if there's personal liability when you break the law. And the thing that makes me frustrated is there would be
但我不想说任何会让我陷入法律麻烦的话，但我不想使用那家公司。如果保险公司告诉我必须这样做，我有选择不接受保险或不使用他们的软件的权利。我认为这些垄断是不好的。我希望消费者知道这一点，也希望提供者知道这一点。像这样的公司违法赚的钱远多于被抓后需要支付的罚款。这是一个糟糕的先例。如果你把做这种事的管理人员送进监狱，他们就会停止，因为他们不想坐牢。如果违法时有个人责任，他们就会停止。让我感到沮丧的是……
personal liability if it was me. If I did this, somebody wouldn't say, okay, just refund some co-pays. I would get kicked out of a Blue Cross panel. A lot of things would happen. So I think it is our responsibility to hold these companies accountable. And that doesn't mean that all the people who work there are bad. And that doesn't mean that, you know, there's, it doesn't mean that you have to like go out and blast them on Facebook. I don't really think that's effective. But it just means that you have to recognize that this is a big deal and be vocal about who you use as a provider. Because when the healthcare is under the control of a monopoly, then everyone who's providing or receiving
如果是我，会有个人责任。如果我做了这种事，不会有人说“好吧，退还一些共付额就行了”。我会从蓝十字保险小组中被除名。很多事情都会发生。所以我认为我们有责任让这些公司承担责任。这并不意味着在那里工作的所有人都是坏人。这也不意味着你必须去Facebook上抨击他们。我不认为那有效。但这确实意味着你必须认识到这是一件大事，并对你选择的提供者大声疾呼。因为当医疗保健处于垄断控制之下时，那么每一个提供或接受……
healthcare doesn't have a choice anymore. And these corporate tech monopolies scare me as a therapist. So I've been very careful to limit my own liability and like what I'm saying, because I, a lot of these things are alleged or, you know, I wasn't the one who has the data. I'm reading the news too and trusting that to be true. So, you know, I have every reason to believe that this is what I'm saying is right, but you know but there's a margin of error in that I don't have all the information. I don't have the data that they sent to Facebook. But at Taproot, we receive a high quality of, or we try and provide a high quality of privacy for you. And we also personalize every referral that we get. I mean, we want to take care of you. We don't want you to just come here. We want you to get therapy, even if it's not with us. And we recognize that
医疗保健的人就再也没有选择了。作为一名治疗师，这些企业科技垄断让我感到害怕。所以我非常小心地限制我自己的责任，以及我所说的话，因为很多事情都是涉嫌的，或者我并不是拥有数据的人。我也在看新闻，并相信它是真实的。所以，我有充分的理由相信我所说的是对的，但其中存在误差，我并没有所有的信息。我没有他们发送给Facebook的数据。但在Taproot，我们接收高质量的，或者我们试图为你提供高质量的隐私保护。我们也个性化我们收到的每一个转诊。我们想照顾你。我们不希望你只是来这里。我们希望你得到治疗，即使不是和我们一起。我们认识到……
we're not the best provider for every person. And so even though we have a month waitlist, a lot of the time or a couple month waitlist, we return every call, even when we're full. And we try and get you with somebody who's accepting patients, which means we have a short list of people who are accepting patients. And sometimes when the industry is underwater, that's really hard. And we still do it because I have a higher loyalty to the ethics of this profession. And I would like for those to be legally enforced. But if our legislators are failing to do that, then I will still do it. But I think that you shouldn't have the choice. I don't think that you should just have to obey the ethics because you decided to.
我们不是每个人的最佳提供者。所以即使我们经常有几个月的等待名单，我们也会回复每一个电话，即使我们已经满了。我们试图为你匹配一个正在接收病人的治疗师，这意味着我们有一个正在接收病人的简短名单。有时当行业处于困境时，这真的很难。但我们仍然这样做，因为我对这个行业的道德有更高的忠诚度。我希望这些道德能被法律强制执行。但如果我们的立法者没能做到这一点，我仍然会这样做。但我认为你不应该有选择权。我不认为你应该仅仅因为你决定遵守道德就去遵守。
I think that you should have to obey the ethics because if you don't, you broke the law and there's a consequence that did not happen here. This is Joel. If you have a question, please send me an email and check out our website, GetTherapyBirmingham.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为你应该遵守道德，因为如果你不遵守，你就违法了，并且会有后果，而这里并没有发生这种情况。我是Joel。如果你有任何问题，请给我发电子邮件，并查看我们的网站GetTherapyBirmingham.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。